hi guys Ryan the right here hi Sally the
wrong Oh
we're gonna watch the trailer really
we're gonna watch the trailer for I Love
Lucy the comedy does not stop funny I
just realized I have red hair like Lucy
you're Hispanic like I'm huh that's the
worst Ricardo impression ever yeah we
should do a spin-off or an update a new
television series with guys make a
petition make a position we're gonna be
the new Lucy and Ricky so we're gonna
watch the trailer for Lucy starring
Scarlett Johansson I know a couple
things about this movie I know Luke
Bates son is involved and I like him
even though they make some pretty shitty
movies now but I loved the fifth element
a lot the professional and Scarlett
Johansson hottest ass ever
damn would I want to squeeze it right
right and your Sally is um she's up
there with Scarlett I think so she is
and you look at her take her and Spri
shot her
good job what are you doing would say
Robert De Niro figure sexy face let's
see it don't do that ever
I'll just show you might but dude stop
living good images in there we go this
is great she thinks she's like not funny
to hear summary guess my boyfriend is
like the son of the director of an
improv comedy theater so I'm always
gonna warm up him and it yeah that's
tough gosh you and your boyfriend gets
in the way of my attraction for you
Sally
you thought they covered videos you just
look - he's like Kito him - stop hitting
on you on the Internet
so I was like I do it all the time to
myself I've never actually attempted
something Lucy Lucy ha ha
every time I'm with you I just I'm so
happy like I all the time I'm not oh
well there's a reason why so I heard
this movie was like the girl version of
limitless let's see if that's true if so
that would be kind of sad because why
would you want to do that maybe
limitless is pretty [ __ ] sweet yeah
the girl version so she sleeps with a
bunch of guys doing married a lie why do
I have this horrible image of a boy yeah
that's really [ __ ] up anyway let's
watch this trailer kid it's plain
Universal but it's just in my psyche
[Music]
you've merely slipped a new package into
your lower tummy and you're going to
transport something very special
Oh creepy oh damn it shock
[ __ ] with the wrong [ __ ]
oh that's so cool oh god that's cold
[Music]
she's smart damn izes sweets inside me I
need you to take it out yes professor
Norman my name is Lucy I just read all
the research on the brain it's a little
rudimentary but you're on the right
track
mr. Eagle capacity whoa
[Music]
I can sort of see the limitless makes
you super humans
whoa what the [ __ ] that's like a science
fiction now that's so cool
you'll unlock secrets that go beyond the
pace son I said it right about powerful
female human
yeah
I'm not sure what's going on but it
looks really cool I totally was
[Music]
look sweet dude let's see you'll [ __ ] up
[ __ ] creek car doesn't wait why did they
even bother giving morgan freeman a
fictional name in every movie when
clearly like he should just be working
he is Freeman he's cool he's just a
great job though every time
Scott Johansen man she's gonna together
any other girl doing this it may be
quite honest well I mean her career
after like the Avengers yeah she just
came out with a movie that came out the
same day Captain America didn't she got
great reviews for yeah yeah they yessir
recommending that trailer because like
the effects look great the action looks
awesome I love the evolution of power I
thought they gave away a little too much
especially when she's freezing Times
Square yeah that's a lot of powers
you're showing us it does look really
awesome it's gonna be one hell of a film
and Scott James needle rocket I hope to
see you ask that part wish you'd spread
her legs yeah like damn pretty
comparable though when Sally was kind of
mooning us with her pants on let's do it
again Sally this time take your pants
off okay but if you're new to the
channel so you can see my boobs on my
channel there you go that's how ya
people watch it whenever I see you see
the little bit of cleavage I just
started clapping right away or movie see
Morgan Freeman Sally's boobs are Morgan
Freeman is one of the two often bitter
coffee or something like that I think I
got a right Cofer your you have another
song or gonna break it comes out like a
girl I know named hazel Grover
DJ production flix productions likes ya
see that that's a unique shout-out we
did that just but sounds like a DJ get
it man I believe your name is Sir James
sir James I am requesting that you watch
the Lucy train up in the sky requested
over and over again though I watch this
trailer and you know what man this video
mainly dedicated to you because he left
one comment that just kept going
watch it lose each other watch the
losers it was like The Shining when he's
like no working because you requested
this trailer isn't that hot okay every
time she talks in that accent penis
rises a little I talked in his accent
like right after Noah because of Emma
Watson and he about lost it I did I had
to go to the bathroom for a few minutes
when she started talking that way yeah
it was really quick too quick I did it
again